two options you either follow my rules  or follow my rules  capiche thank you I can do it a  different way that's that's fine thank  you very much  you  your fire it's a Christmas yeah I see  the decorations good luck in the new  year I just read your play and I wanted  it strange that we keep running into  each other maybe it means something I  doubt it  yeah you could just write your own roles  you know write something that's as  interesting as you are what are you  gonna do yeah my own Club  that can happen every time I think so  how are you gonna be a revolutionary if  it's such a traditionalist you holding  on to the Past but jazz is about the  future maybe I'm not good enough yes you  are maybe I'm not it's like a pipe dream  this is a drink it's conflict and it's  compromise it's very very exciting  so  haha  you  foolish as they may seem  here's two thoughts